où
[Musique]
d'avril à juin à the sea cloud
déjà douze du petit os montes tout
autour
oh
sa capture
[Musique]
six espèces
transformers transformers de la snrt
[Musique]
séné comme une légende la plus grande de
tout nous avons cassé durant milan pour
protéger la terre du sort qui lui
étaient destinées optimus prime tu as
détruit ton monde
tu cherches la rétention wima créatrice
je la cherche
[Musique]
à ta fille qu'est ce que tu lui dirai
aussi toile et dans fais tes devoirs
traîne pas avec un maquis et dans un
groupe surtout le batteur
nous vivons des heures sombres sans
leader le chaos s'installe
de monde entrent en collision
et vous êtes notre dernier espoir
désormais la plus grande émission
changer le sorte d'humanité
st
la destruction de tout ce que nous
connaissons les que nous aimons a
commencé
je partirai pas sans toi
semble perdu quelques âmes courageuses
sauver tout ce qui nous est cher
l'opération est terminée on lâche pas
optimus hockey
vous restez
et moi aussi je veux me battre
[Musique]
survivent
le vôtre doit à mourir
m
[Musique]